and then finally you get it you say but
my Creator I come to you with this
knowledge in my life most of it what how
not to be in what not to do but I have
all this knowledge you got it you're
coming to me with the knowledge of your
life that's beautiful on this very value
and then at that moment you you come to
them with the knowledge of your life
very powerful and then it's in the
morning the other opens the door and
says oh you have to come back but you
don't want to come back why should I
come back I mean why should I be a
stupid human being I don't want to come
back I don't want to confine my spirit
in that body because I'm I'm one with
everything
why would I limit myself to be a human
being someone's opinion may contradict
yours where's my friend Allen it's all
about your perspective who are we and
what is the nature of this reality
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sock young we're on site
at the American Anthropological
Association Annual Meeting
for our second partnership with them we
are now sitting down with Douglas
Cardinal hi Douglas thanks for coming on
the program it's nice to be here
wonderful to be in Vancouver yeah you
had such a profound keynote last night
where we were immersed in your world
renowned architectural experience design
blending together spirituality and
nature into your projects that you've
worked on and I've been talking to you
quite a bit since last night and I'm
really grateful that you came on the
program I want to talk to you about this
most first principle question are we
really all one yes where my experience
which the elders put me through in order
to start reconnecting myself to my mind
body and spirit
my experience is working with them that
we're all one were all interconnected to
all of life and all of life around us
and and throughout the universe were
connected to the planet the very core of
this planet we're connected to each
other and connected to every animal bird
fish plant and everything else and our
elders don't teach us that because then
it comes to our heads the elders have to
actually have us feel that so in their
ceremonies in the Vision Quest you
actually go through a life and death
experience you see the only way you're
going to learn that you're part of all
creation is that you have to go to the
other side and back and in that journey
you will see how connected you are to
our life and what is this other side
that you speak other side Vision Quest
after death is post death okay yeah so
near-death experiences what our division
quests that the elders send you on well
to feel the oneness feel the oneness
well you're asked to go
I mean you because you're searching for
this answer you're feeling entirely
disconnected with me the church and
state through my mind disconnected me
from my from my body and my spirit and
from everything around me it's such a
way that I would totally lose feelings
in my hands and feet and my mind would
be disconnected from my body and I would
I would then gradually those feelings in
my body and until I would go unconscious
and and that created a tremendous stress
on my my body my turn early organs and
particularly my kidneys because they
would stop functioning and then I was in
real trouble
so the outers
they came and took me out of the
hospital and said we need you oh we
don't have time for this you better come
and be with us and we'll we'll make you
whole again so
and of course I had a thirst for living
and so I said if he can help me with
this because nothing seems to help me I
mean I'm totally the doctors when I went
to University of Texas felt that I had
the same illness that astronauts get
when they get out in space get totally
disconnected because they're out in
space and there's no connection to the
planet and and they go through this
process of where they feel this
tremendous anxiety where their mind and
body seem disconnected and you go
through tremendous ready to go and you
you lose feeling of your whole body and
and you go unconscious and so the
challenge is how to get you back on your
feet again and with me it was I when I
started getting these things the only
thing I could do would be run out into
the forest and and tear all civilization
away from me and said under a tree yes
so that I could start connecting to to
earth yes but
the more I got into our urban
environment and working in our urban
environment and and that whole way of
life which is sort of disconnecting
oneself totally from nature and from
each other I found it that I would
continually get these stress attacks to
a point where my kidneys stopped
functioning and I know it's been real
trouble and so the elders took me out of
the hospital and said we need you we
don't have time for this and so you're
going to come up with us and they they
there are ceremonies were against the
law at that time so they left their
communities and went to the mountain
created the camp
the chief robert small boy created a
camp for all the elders could come and
practice their traditions and their
ceremonies so they took me up to the
mountains and then they brought me back
but I had to learn how to connect myself
to my shell if I was totally
disconnected this seems like absolutely
the most first principled thing about
life is that we come from the one and
that we no matter what path you take
back up this mountain to wreak immune
with the one to drop or this wave must
rejoin the ocean and must have the
experience of rejoining the ocean to
truly understand the nature of this
reality at its most principled level and
then that the fact that there's so many
people humans that have not done that
process of Rica Munich with this
infinite one that then
that is the most upstream root issue
that all of our world faces we face the
feelings of separation of
disconnectedness yes and I sensed a Mars
after that experience I've had by
connecting myself with the one because I
particularly was against every religion
and every spiritual thing after I was
came out of the residential school I was
totally turned against anything that had
to do with religion or spirituality and
that was being really disconnected but
so the process that the elders had and
it and it was passed down for thousands
of years it was a really a process where
at first we had to go through a sweat
lodge it's a purification Rite and then
not sweat lodge you you bring in the
rocks
redhot rocks and you bring in the water
and you go back to the origins of the
planet where it's the water on the rocks
of brought life
and then you relive that experience
where you go in there and it is
unbelievably scalding hot and that's
because you have to surrender you have
to get off your arrogance and the only
way you can the elder will keep pouring
the water in there until until you reach
out and pray to something that's beyond
yourself you reach out to the creator of
us all and there are special songs that
are sung that help you go on that
spiritual journey of reaching out beyond
yourself and asking the Creator to come
and help you through the experience
because your mind will stop you will
tell you are you crazy are you not see
ya what are you doing in this place you
know you're gonna get hurt and you're
gonna burn and you're going to you might
even die in here I mean and so it scares
the [ __ ] out of you so he can't listen
to your mind you got to listen to the
songs and if your mind is giving you a
rough time the elder may distract your
mind like this with a rattle to distract
your mind because the mind it will be on
a one-way track it is concerned about
your preservation yeah and so it's
scaring the [ __ ] out of you yeah - to
stop this they use a rattle to interfere
with the monkey mind racing away yeah
that's what all the rattle is you answer
interesting and it brings you back to
the oneness yeah because you it
distracts to Maya and all of a sudden
you know your your mind
is just another noise that you're
dealing with the rattles are more
important in there because if you're if
you you might be distracted enough where
he'll bang your head with a rattle so
that you you don't have your mind see
it's your mind that that is the problem
child here it's a mind that disconnected
you it's your own ego and feeling that
of your own self-importance your own ego
and I've got to be in charge and in
there it's pitch black and there's no
way out the roots go right down willows
go right down and you can't get out and
so you make a commitment to go in and
the door is not open when you yell open
the door it's too hot sorry you made
that commitment to be in here the door
isn't open until the elder says the door
is open
Wow and so you're trapped in there what
are you gonna do I mean what if you're
in a car accident you're trapped in a
burning car what are you going to do you
have to surrender she so Wow you you
will surrender would you see sweat
lodges are that close to near-death
experiences well the elder that decided
that he was going to make me whole yes
oh my god
it's a purification Rite Wow and and
because you're out of balance and if and
he can see the aura of your lifeforce
and there are holes in your aura or
trauma of that you caused yourself that
imbalance is your body so those are your
things that you're doing to your body
and say also a healing Lodge yes because
believes that all that the body is
designed to totally defend itself it has
all sorts of ways you know healing
itself because it keeps regenerating
itself like like the I can't remember
how many months it takes for the eye to
totally replace every cell every
molecule in your eye is being replaced
so your body is in a continual state of
dying and rebirth every cell in your
body and after I can't remember how many
years it is I think maybe seven years I
think so too every cell in your body is
replaced every molecule in your body is
replaced so you're continually changing
and living and dying all the time every
cell and if you caused some traumas in
your experience it can affect the cells
in your body to such a point where when
it regenerates it has flaws in it and
that's what creates a lot of illnesses
because most of the our illnesses as far
as our elders are concerned are
psychosomatic
yeah they're created by our way of
thinking yeah and our whole immune
system can heal balance ourselves so in
a large you see the person's aura there
are dark spots where where the mind is
interfered yes with the with the energy
field but the wholeness the Holies and
you can in the aura you can see those
dark spots of where this this
psychosomatic okay you have the minds
interfering so the elder will take the
egos way and go home and right to that
spot it's just like a spear going
through you go the Eagle wind yeah
to the dark spot in the world yeah and
that is it's like the mind won't let go
of that rage that whatever incident has
caused you
whether it's paint somebody's hurt you
or so you have deep rage yes and that
deep rage is separating you yes from
that spirit yes so you go through this
very difficult sweat lodge but it's not
just a healing lodge is to prepare you
for your fast for the fast yeah and how
long's the fast the fast is five days
yes without water or food yes yeah dry
fast yeah yeah five days and four nights
you know water yep and Wow
and this is the reach so this is the the
experience that they take you on the
elders take you on so that you can
really feel as close this communion with
the one yeah it's a near-death
experience for you sweat lodge - so
that's large and the fast yeah
interesting and what age do they take
the you well it's what any whenever
anybody feels that they what they have
the courage to go on because it's a hell
of a commitment does it happen as young
as like ten years old or as late as Oh
70 years old no it's probably when you
start dealing with as a young adult
dealing with life in general 15 ish 20
ish 25 plus the guys in there were of
course
our teachings are separated from us but
I see young men doing it you know maybe
20 and do women go through a ritual like
this as well yeah ceremony
okay the women can deal with it better
because they know how to deal with pain
because they give childbirth yeah
they're more connected yeah because
they're connected they're reminded every
month yes the lunar cycle that they're
connected to the moon and to the earth
and us guys have nothing to remind us
like that yeah so that's why we need
sweat lodge frankly I do a sweat lodge
every week could have done for 50 years
every week for 50 years now yeah yeah
yeah Wow
and that that's so interesting that you
bring up how women have a part of their
reproductive process that actually
reminds them about their
interconnectedness to the one and how
it's tied to the moon and how US men
need a sweat lodge to remind us about
the one we needed dry fast we need these
other processes that tie us to the one
this I want to ask this question as well
that for from the elders to the rest of
the world it seems to be the most common
theme around indigenous talking to this
younger brother that is in these
metropolis that is going and and
tinkering and creating and exploring but
also in many ways causing destructive
harm that to remember the processes of
the deep interconnection to nature into
each other into the one that seems to be
the most common message from elders and
that there what are the best things for
the younger brother to do you gave us
this example of you know the sweat
lodges the dry fast
just going into the middle of the trees
and just sitting and connecting what are
the best processes for the younger
brother and the metropolis is to do well
what I've seen is you when you're when
you're so disconnected and here's a
trouble with your mind you self-medicate
with drugs and alcohol and and I found
and I've helped the elders put together
initiatives like the Nietzsche
foundation it uses the traditional
elders to help the young urbanites to
get away from drugs and alcohol by
following the traditional ways because
once you follow them you don't have time
for drugs and alcohol
in fact he realized that in harming
yourself you're going against all of
creation and you have to learn how to
honor yourself yes because particularly
if you go on the long fasts because our
experience is indescribably
I could describe it because from from my
perspective
to go on a long fast and there are
different ways
my elder and some of the elders have you
go on the fast sequence is different a
lot of the elders have a feast and then
a know a sweat lodge and then a feast
and go for five days without water food
my elder and had these ceremonies and
how does go on a feast and then the
sweat lodge and then go and fasting and
after his sweat lodge experience the
sweat lodge experience is usually four
rounds and the doors open each round and
you just feel like you're gonna pass out
or pass away you know and then he opens
the door yeah so there are four rounds
like that
so the coulis you're getting to that
feeling of passing out the near-death
and then the door opens and then you're
the relief comes and then again the same
process just like the fastest two five
days you feel towards the end like I
need the water I need the food but
you're overcoming the monkey mind that's
constantly trying to rush you to those
specific things except by outer the way
he would do the
be a little different you'd have your
feast and then you'd go into the sweat
lodge and then you had to do all four
rounds and he would not open the door
yeah
in no door no more open I it was like
how can I not surrender more than I have
you'd be just like a lump then you go
through and you'd be totally dehydrated
whoo yeah you feel like you could spit
dust because your body is just total oh
there's no it just seems there's no
water in your body anymore you're
totally sweated it all out and you
really want a drink of water and then
you'd say then you go out and fast yeah
without water without water yeah for
five day ago Douglas what do you think
is but you'd go through on that Foust he
would guide you through no you would be
sitting out in a nature of a spot that
he's chosen that's a power point he
chose for you for that past and and it
would be made out of willows and you had
to the only way you could survive would
be at par with a blade of grass like you
had to not be any more important yeah
and that blade of grass Wow
they would pick a location for you and
you would stay in that location you'd
stay in that Lodge and each willow you
had to make the lodge before you go into
the feast for but for five days though
would you stay in the same location yeah
and you could you had to feel that you
were the same importance as the blade of
grass yeah and the Willows that you cut
or the lodge it's a
I just don't at you can just sit up in
when you're holding a sacred pipe and
you sit up in there and it's open to the
West the Setting Sun yeah and and you
can you you when you go in there each
willow eye has to be that you put
together you you have to go to the
willow tree the spirit of that willow
and you have to say to the willow I'm
going to take your life your life is
important but I want you I'm going to
take your life because I want to learn
about the spirit of us all mmm
and I'll use your life in that way so
that I will always respect the willows
in a little spirit and I'll give you an
offering before I take your life
interesting so there's a ceremonial
offering that's given to the willow yeah
then you take the spirit because you
want to become one with it yes and then
you and you say I want to become at one
with a spirit of all life yes your
spirit yes and I will I will honor you
and use you in a good way and so you
these projects yeah so hats like this
and you are very deliberate because you
swiftly take the life of the willow and
so you make sure you're really accurate
four times and then you go whack it
takes out well oh and you realize that
you've taken a life of another creature
and that's what we do we all the reason
we survive is I take the life of other
creatures so they're all all of life
around us are our life givers yeah so
even our food we've taken life from a
plant or an animal for our food yes
which all comes from the Sun yeah to
fuel the energy of that plant that we
then eat yeah but that plan is a
life-giver and requires the same respect
they're part of us yeah and we can so we
have to make sure that we do things in a
loving and caring way as our elders say
yes because we have to care for that
there they were sacrificing their life
for us yes yes so we have to honor that
and so and then when we make the lodge
we when we put the lodge into the earth
we use red ochre on the bottom of the
sharpened willow to remind us that we
are piercing our mother the earth and
our mother the earth is also part of the
spirit it's a spirit itself it is a life
force itself and our mother the earth is
alive yes and is a powerful spirit
itself so we humble ourselves by saying
to our mother
we are always causing you such pain and
we're causing a pain to build its Lodge
and we have to remember that we have to
honor and respect our mother yes these
rituals are so important
well they they're important because we
are always in control
and we're always disregarding our
environment around us the food we eat we
just take it for granted
yeah and there the elder says you cannot
take these things for granted because if
you you will you won't be able to
commune with the spirit if you take
these things for granted every breath of
air every bite of food every interaction
with nature and all other humans nothing
is for granted everything is sacred and
to see the divinity in that process you
have these rituals that help highlight
the divinity in all of those processes
you have to follow those ways if you do
not he will say you're not ready to do
this fast yeah you haven't prepared your
mind for this if you still our arrogant
creature yeah and Wow
and so you have to really prepare
yourself for a year to make sure you do
this in a right way if you're gonna
learn anything and in which indigenous
do this the sweat lodge the dry fast
which indigenous all Anishinabe peoples
all Anishinabe
I'm talking about and I understand
ritual and anise Nabi the Haudenosaunee
people have the same it's a very similar
rituals but they do things a little
different they they turn their lodges to
another direction and we always go into
our large clockwise yes and hood nashoni
go ahead a clockwise yeah they just have
different each each elder has a
different way of doing things that were
passed down to him but our he learns it
by going through these ceremonies and
and he he gets two ceremonies from the
crater of us all so yes
what on though he gets the pipe the
sacred pipe or the ceremony was all like
we have to say I wanted to fast or the
sacred pipe so I asked the elder he
would because I knew that that was when
I held on to the sacred pipe I felt a
connection and it my vertical went away
okay I'll pass for the sacred pipe and
then I would solve my problems so so
that I was holding the sacred pipe in
the lodge to go through this whole
ceremony this vision question yes this
is comparing these styles of vision
quests and experiences that immerse us
into the wisdom of the
interconnectedness of the one versus the
serious levels of disconnection that are
existing in the metropolis is there
needs to be a global transition in terms
of an evolution of consciousness towards
indigeneity in order for us to actually
be able to figure out how to maximize
prosperity going forward and it seems as
though this happening from both a you
give all these these rituals will these
rituals to not only happen from a
grassroots level of people but also to
go to the places like the biggest
government's in the world the biggest
corporations in the world and just you
know grabbing the top executives and and
public officials and just you they have
to do these rituals that way they
actually did the experience the ego
death they experienced the
interconnectedness with the one all of
their decisions downstream become
oriented towards the unity the oneness
and not
towards their own self-dealing
egotistical habits yeah that that is why
we used went through these ceremonies
because we had to get often in terms of
her self-importance in order to be able
to work with nature be a part of nature
and to and to support each other and
govern each other properly loving and
caring his ritual is very important from
where the foundation of our culture
see because hunter-gatherers the need to
have a special relationship with the
environment their lives depend on it
yes as soon as you become a member of
the agrarian culture and start
manipulating the earth like agrarian
cultures then you know you don't you
know and and not rely on nature for your
livelihood and your life then you lose
all of that you know many of the leaders
we talked to talked about that moment of
transition from immediate return
hunter-gathering to the agrarian society
ya know
the Haudenosaunee are agrarian and and
they have retained their rituals and so
interesting about wooden ishani our
agrarian yeah they they grow corn squash
beans yeah you can still be very
connected and grow food yeah yeah yeah
odd nashoni weird that way the Mohawks
and but they were more warlike because
they had defend their crops and whereas
in even defending our territories it was
not right to kill another human being
our warriors yeah you you actually
taught us about this last night when we
were talking he said that wolves even if
they come to thee to dominate another
wolf at the neck they won't kill another
of their own species in that you said
that another example of a similar trait
is that when two tribes will then have a
member of one of the tribes go and marry
a member of the other tribe and
procreate with them marry but just
procreate with them therefore then if
there is conflict between those tribes
they would not then kill one of the
descendants of their own lineage those
children and so over time then it is as
though then it does become that oneness
more so I love these things that you are
passing
along to us yeah the the communities
encouraged their young women to to marry
a member of the their enemy Wow yeah
because they were there were another
human being but so that they would be
part of it family and Wow and this is
why us-chinese relations right now are
very important marry us people marry
Chinese people Chinese food marry us
people so that we can make sure that the
the geopolitical climate stays lovely
and harmonious that's why we all that
Navi people lived in harmony with each
other although we had some rough
skirmishes but it was not the crater's
way to to kill each other yeah that is a
crime against the
the Creator to do that absolutely
Douglas I need to ask you this question
what what is the point of creation
making this why did creation make this
we were growing and evolving and and
in the long fast what I have discovered
there's a point where you learn at first
you're going through a lot of pain
you're thirsty and whatever so the
elders said you're going to have to be
able to communicate with all the life
around you and you start realizing you
don't even belong in this damn earth
they're away your mind is operating
you're bitten by mosquitoes and you're
by ants and you're and it's
uncomfortable and sitting on the grass
and the scratches you're like what am I
doing here I I don't even belong here
you know you start realizing that you
you and you have to in a sense start
communicating with all of these
creatures around you so and start
talking to the grouse start talking to
their trees yes you start communicating
and and you and then you're saying give
me give me this part of the life force
that you have can you give me some of
your life force so that I can survive
this experience and then you ask the
grass can you help me through this yes
which I had on the grass and the grass
all of a sudden you feel life coming
into your hand from the grass you can
feel it coming in at you oh thank you my
grass where you walk over the tree and
against the tree and say
please give me some of your energy so
that I can survive this day then you
feel energy you say the clouds please
give me the spirit of the water so that
I can quench my thirst and then you find
all of these spiritual energies start
helping you and you you feel that you're
being fed by energy by all the creatures
around you they're all supporting you
yes
to such an extent that you feel your
total spirit that you can walk right
through a tree that you not physical
anymore and you feel that you just total
spirit and that all the spirits around
you are feeding you so you surrender and
you become humble and you ask for the
life force from the other plants animals
around you you you you know that there
at this moment they're more important
than you because you're you're four days
into the dry fast yeah and here here but
then what happens is you the other says
you know I your mind is is really
against what you're doing and giving you
a hard time and you what are you doing
talking to the plant the grass what are
you doing talking to the ants and the
butterflies squirrels whatever you out
of your mind you know and so the mind is
giving you a rough time yeah
but then after you gain all this energy
and you feel I'm so powerful that I can
fly like I don't even have to be in this
body I'm out I'm total energy Wow
I'm just powerful energy I don't eat
this fast the owner said you watch out
her mind is gonna twist your on try to
trick you holy they get you off
sebastian off your commitment don't this
time that the horse day don't listen to
your mind mind was giving you a rough
time before and i was trying to
sweet-talk me tossed you out of out of
this commitment horses the mind is so
powerful and so tricky eunice not your
mind is not your friend the ego is not
the amigo yeah it's not your friend
it's gonna keep you from the power
spirit around you so then you you feel
all powerful all filled with spirit and
then it's the last night is the hardest
because when you see the sun goes down
all the all of the life seems to go down
with the Sun yeah and it's like the
trees here that gave you energy the
energy goes back to the trees goes back
to the grass goes back to everything and
that all of a sudden you feel that you
can't even have the energy to blink your
eyes you're just wow just your body has
no more energy and then and then you you
feel just your light around you and then
there's a big light that comes around
you and totally surrounds you and pulls
you out of your body and you're looking
down at your body as a shell and it's
absolutely terrifying see oh my god I'm
gonna die I'm not gonna I'm gonna leave
my body I don't want to you know
you know and so so then this spirit this
being is overwhelming it just takes you
and you don't have control of what you
think this is an illusion my mind is
doing crazy things on me I mean and then
you say I don't believe in what's
happening and then it goes takes your
body again then finally you realize that
this spirit is taking your life horse
out of your body and this is a powerful
force that that you can't control so
then you start trying to bargain with it
you're trying to do anything like I
don't want to die I mean you know don't
take me and all that and the more you
fight it the more it takes you and you
go no no no no I don't want to die you
know I don't want to go and finally you
says you arrogant creature you don't
have control over your life and death
such an arrogant creature you know as if
you have control as if you have control
yeah and and then see do you have
control and then you're you're taking on
your body and you look back and you go
and then you come and you have to
totally surrender to it you know why
don't you think of all the things you
see I creator
let thy will be done what do you mean
let thy will be done you arrogant
creature as if you have a choice you
don't have a choice
who do you think you are arrogant
creature and then finally you you just
have to get off it
totally surrendered and not argue with
it you know and it's just so you so then
as you come as you come closer and the
light becomes brighter all of a sudden
you feel like terrible because you're
not worthy that being is so loving and
caring in contrast to the way you've
lived that you you feel you're not
worthy to be able to even touch that
loving and caring it's so caring for you
and and and you start judging yourself
your life stops time stops and your
whole life rolls back and you see
everything they have done in your life
that is that is wrong how you've hurt
people how you've heard others are you
haven't honored your mother and your
father
Wow how you haven't what you've done to
you all the mistakes you've made in your
life is piled right up in you Wow and
you have to go through each one and
you're just it's so painful you just
feel like you're being torn apart it is
the most painful experience of all as
you as you go through analysis of your
life all those shitty things you've done
in your life the thoughtless things
you've done in your life everything else
you go through that time stops and you
go through your whole life and and
you and the closer you come to the
spirit the more pain you feel for being
so stupid and so hurtful and and not a
good person and you just go through a
terrible thing of seeing how you've
heard everybody and you just feel that
you're just a terrible creature you know
and you're not worthy to to be part of
the creation you're not worthy at all
and finally the see this horse stance
stop it stop it stop it you arrogant
creature who do you think you are as if
you had that knowledge like what you
know now about that would you have done
that which you know now no see you see
you're not a bad manipulated creature at
all probably a stupid one you haven't
evolved do you think you're a god do you
think you can judge yourself what are
you doing get off it you can't judge
yourself you didn't know any better
that's why you did that
if you known now going back whatever you
handle that differently yes I would have
done this and this of course you would
have done that not you see because
that's not your nature
you know you can't judge yourself
because you're not evolves yeah mm-hmm
and not evolve to that extent of knowing
yeah what you're doing was wrong you
were heartless you were selfish yes
you're all about yourself and you
thought you were more important and
other people and making this decision or
that decision so you go through your
whole life like that and and that
powerful being guides you through he's
loving and caring and trying to get you
to go off it and have you see that and
then finally you get it that you say but
my creator I come to you with this
knowledge in my life most of it is what
how not to be in what not to do but I
have all this knowledge and he says you
got it you're coming to me with the
knowledge of your life and that's
beautiful and that's very valuable and
then at that moment you they're part of
everything
Wow
can you come to them with the knowledge
of your life very powerful and then it's
in the morning the elder opens the door
and says you have to come back but you
don't want to come back so why should I
come back I mean why should I be a
stupid human being I don't want to come
back I don't want to confine my spirit
in that body because I'm I'm one with
everything
yeah why would I limit myself to be a
human being and the older then comes in
with his sweet cross yeah it's a very
hard time to bring you back because you
don't want to come back he says life is
so beautiful you got to see the sunrise
this morning there's there's a dew on
the grass and the sunlight is sparkling
on the grass and it is magnificent
mm-hmm
says you've got to see how beautiful it
is on this planet yes how amazing
beautiful it is he keeps talking to us
about how beautiful life was beautiful
it is gorgeous like there's no important
it is that's him pitching you to come
back telling you to come back yeah and
you try and you don't want to come back
and finding he keeps telling you
beautiful on these he's using the sweet
grouse and to try to bring you back
bring back to consciousness
Wow you don't want to come back wow so
the more that the elder takes you
through the experience of the sweat
lodge where you feel closer and closer
to this being to this to this near-death
experience where this arrogant creature
that's trying to hold on to dear life is
experiencing this this being that is
that is then flashing all of the moments
time stops all of these moments of all
of the times of of ignorant behavior
towards mother or father or malevolent
behavior towards others
the lack of realization of the
interconnectedness all of these things
flashed before and then this the
realization of the Spirit and the
interconnectedness with the one all is
happening there and then and then those
those moments are the reason why you
don't want to come out of this Lodge
once it's done Andy but there is heaven
on earth happening there's the beautiful
sunrises and sunsets the ecosystems of
the creatures in the plants and beauty
of life and but the beauty of being at
peace with the Creator and at one with a
crater is more beautiful than that as
well because it is a total peace
and so he the outer talks you back
and finally you say greater what he's
talking about is so beautiful and the
creator says yes it is life is beautiful
can I go back for a second and see what
he's talking about
well you're a free spirit you choose
I'll be back I'll be back in a minute
well time is whatever
but I have to see what he's talking
about
when I come back my eyes and just seen I
never seen anything more beautiful than
the Pat moment
and
so then he says you're going to have to
walk with me back to this to the sweat
lodge yes I said so he helps me back to
the lodge and I say you know like what's
that in the distance all that haze no
and why are we walking on this land
that's all plowed you know what have
they done to our mother
mm-hmm says oh we have done that and why
are we doing that and why is that
all that dark haze over there I'm not
about the city over there you're you
just just don't understand and then you
come into the lodge with him and because
only after the second round did you get
your first sip of water yeah so you go
back in the lodge
he puts water on the rocks red hot rocks
super hot there and he started coming
back into your body and then and he says
you say
I really don't want to be here I really
don't like it here look what they're
doing look what they're doing to our
mother the earth yes it's not a good
time
yes Jesus it's not a good time for an
Indian so this is a challenging time of
transition this is a challenging time of
consciousness evolution of for the
younger brother and the metropolis is to
wake up to the elders teachings to the
world you know where I get my first sip
of water it's just so hard to take it
just like my life just coming back in my
body in it painful and so I'm I'm sort
of writhing on the ground
my elder looks at me he says yeah it's
tough to be an Indian and so yeah
Wow yeah says but you're back now yeah
and you've learned something haven't you
yes I have it's good then and and then
we I was holding my pipe and he says
that pipe is a very strong symbol of
your experience I said yes the most
important thing in my life he says yes
but it's a physical it's a physical
thing it's just a pipe you're putting
too much meaning in it I said to me it's
very precious it reminds me of my whole
experience
he says you're too attached to it go
where you have passed it and bury it and
so go there and bury the pipe and I
think oh my goodness it feel like I'm
burying myself
and then I come back and the lodge and
he says you see you can't be so attached
to the physical if you're a spiritual
being yeah it's uh and the pipe when you
get I'll give you in another pipe but so
when you take that pipe you turn in to
the four directions heaven on earth
you'll be reminded that you have a pipe
where you have passed it and it'll
remind you of so you know our pipe
carrier so and you're reminded of your
connection to the creator and what have
you learned well
for one thing you can't be so judgmental
and critical of yourself you have to
care for yourself or I also learned if I
can't criticize myself how can I
criticize others right and so all the
things you've learned is very important
and that's so now you can start this
journey so I said I'm you know what I've
discovered is when I have these terrible
stress attacks if I hear the songs they
seem to go away because it songs are
very powerful so I really have to learn
those songs because you cannot learn
them I says how do I get those songs
that are so powerful so I can keep
myself a balance well you're gonna have
to fast for a gold watch yes
when spirit comes to take you say o my
Creator you can take me if you wish I've
only come here for the songs
and he says that's what you're going to
have to do to get the songs call heck
are you kidding but then there was a
time in working in the urban center that
I needed the song so I came back to him
he says so you come for the song so I
said yeah okay it'll take a year to
prepare yourself for that fast I said
you know not fast is a real challenge I
said I think I I died out there and I
said you know that's what you put me on
but my life in jeopardy
he said you made that decision yourself
and I said what did you've been on these
fasts
what are you experienced exactly the
same exactly why didn't you tell me and
then I wouldn't have had to go I'm not
long fast you could have just told me
what I would experience he says I
couldn't do that because I would have
robbed you the opportunity of you
discovering it yourself by telling you
that you would not have experienced it
and now you know you've experienced it
and is real for you that is not you know
a myth or it doesn't come from my head
as a story you experienced it and that's
real I would have robbed you that
opportunity if I would have told you
yes experiential
so then I had to dad went so I used to
always go to the lodge to get rid of the
my stress attacks and so I learned the
songs by going on a long pass so I could
sing the songs until I went to an elder
sweat who had then knocked the [ __ ] out
of me and and then so I would sing the
songs in the lodge or for one of the
elders finally the elder moved his Lodge
to his community so that I didn't have a
sweat lodge anymore to be able to
survive the city so I went back the
elder and he says now you want to sweat
lodge for yourself
Isis I would really like that I said how
could I do a sweat lodge for myself
wait simply have to Passport
because I can't do it to you only the
spirit can do it
just so again long past this right
launch and then and then said I got my
sweat lodge and then and then I I was
perfectly happy and until some on
canvases Doug I know you have a sweat
lodge can I come and sweat with you
sigh Paul my older said what am I going
to do
did I deny you know well you're going to
have to come here and pass with me to be
able to ask the Creator someone could
come in to lodge with you buddy what say
that I was so people had come in my
sweat lodge and I could run the lodge
you know make sure that it'd be okay for
the people in the lodge yeah and then
somebody then asked me if I would do a
doctor collage with an ego swing and I
mister can I do that yeah you can write
him it said bugger good after climbing
faster all they said you know well did I
deny you you know and you have to care
for people and if they need it
you should be available for them I was
available for you
so that I have fast with him and that
was a very hard fast Rafi goes with this
real doesn't that's the journey here we
come
yes this reoccurring theme of indigenous
wisdom around the world of figuring out
the different rituals ceremonies
strategies INRI communing with the one
and feeling that true yoga as
experiential wisdom this union with the
one for all the different methodologies
that exist this seems to be by far the
most first principle thing that every
child needs to experience as they come
into this world and that we ourselves in
our metropolis need to look at what the
elders and what this indigenous wisdom
is and embody it and realize it to
ensure a prosperous future Douglas this
has been such a fascinating conversation
with you I am so grateful I'm so honored
that we were able to pass this how thank
you gather and when I'm working with a
priest like other mercs when I need to
church with him and then after and I
it's a I'm sorry that you went through
you know a convent experience because we
used to have that connection in the
church we do all of us do these
ceremonies and so understand
his thing is I believe that your path is
very important and I respect and we
became good friends
and so
because I believe it's universal but
that many cultures have that experience
and any rituals I've experienced and
the old cultures the hunter-gatherer
cultures the old cultures they had the
same experience the same connection with
the Creator yes
and I find that with the indigenous
people in China yes I've been asked to
go and work with some of the indigenous
people there they have these very
different ceremonies but they're like
the same yeah so when they come to
Ottawa
they asked me can you can we have a
sweat lodge together and you know I had
the most people are a very matriarchal
the only probably strongest matriarchal
community in China they still have their
language their culture their ceremonies
and everything so the Mosul princess she
says to me she came to Ottawa can we
ever sweat together he said sure so she
went through this work with me and she
says when I went through this wife my
third eye opened to my ancestors she
said she says we had a similar ceremony
but we lost it 200 years ago do you
think your elders can come talk to my
elders and maybe we can get it back so
there's that kind of connection
is universal I feel two people and I
know there was a shaman who actually was
a shaman from China very powerful man
who is a scholar and who was actually a
member of the of the government because
the Chinese government although all the
ministers are Hans a lot of top people
in government our scholars and so he was
a top member of the government was a
scholar but he was also a shaman and
because they only hire scholars because
they feel they need input which I found
really interesting
so he wanted to meet me at the Museum so
I met him at the Museum and they're
having lunch together he says I
understand this building I walked
through this building and I understand
it and he laughs me
that's my niece's only another shaman
can understand this building he says
yeah yes it's a universal language yes
and so it's really interesting you know
how no matter where you go indigenous
people everywhere have that connection
yes
my wife is Basque yeah she's an
indigenous person we have that same
connection and her uncle is a priest and
her mother matriarchal her her family
her fun we decided to get married in in
in Las Vegas her mother called something
that's not a marriage you come come home
now yeah we have to do it right and so
she decided that we would get married in
the center at Leola the center of the
Jesuits by her brother who has a priest
so it's a shared principle of indigenous
wisdom around our world is to wreak
immune with the one and this is the most
important thing for us to bring into our
modernity and incorporate embody the
true wisdom of it Douglas again thank
you for coming on the program this is
well such an honor thank you thank you
yeah and I thank the elders for all
their teachings
likewise yes yes younger brother wake up
to these teachings
thank you everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments blonde the
episode let us know what you're thinking
about all the things that Douglass has
been teaching us we would love to hear
from you check out the links in the bio
below two more of Douglass's work also
check out the links in the bio blow to
the American Anthropological Association
check them out and support them you can
support our show as well you can find
all of our show links below and support
the artists the entrepreneurs spiritual
leaders the organizations around the
world that you believe in and go and
build the future we commune with the one
manifest your dreams into the world we
love very much thank you for tuning in
every day we're all brothers and sisters
that's a wrap okay it was incredible
thank you to all this thank you thank
you yeah I'm so
[Music]
you
[Music]